é muito mais difícil subir um palco para
falar do canditado acredita é assim como
um país fora de água neste momento é
todos nós temos sonhos eo tamanho da
nossa felicidade é proporcional à
capacidade da realizada em questões
eu percebi isso não cedo quando um dia
ouvi uma voz de anjo num ecrã de
televisão estava um dos mais calorosos
país da história da obra universal ou
seja iria ouvir uma cantora para mim é
muito especial e limitada numerosa é que
hoje está acima de 70 anos e que foi uma
das maiores gil das do rigoletto de
verdi de todos os tempos como eu nasci
numa família em tradição musical o meu
primeiro impacto ouvir esta voz foi como
é possível isto não é um menino e para
falar desta profissão que pensam ser um
hobby ou algo que eu tenho que contar a
história da minha vida pois bem quando
eu ouvi esta voz
eu era uma mera estudantes do violino no
conservatório de coimbra
gostava de música não já não podia viver
sem música nessa altura mas estava muito
longe de saber o que seria a minha vida
trinta anos depois
curiosamente quando houve essa tal voz
humana
fui à descoberta
e tentar perceber o que é que fazia
dessa voz tão diferente de um cantor que
tentava uma canção pop
ontem mesmo dada inclusive uma
interpretação jazzística e curiosamente
o que fazia com que essa voz rustam
parecida com os sons que eu procurava
reproduzido no meu violino
o que faz de um cantor lírico
ultrapassar o caminho limite da
tessitura que nós estamos já estamos
habituados a ouvir cantar you música pop
na música ligeira é que nós
desenvolvemos todo o nosso aparelho
vocal do forma a ultrapassar a oitava da
fala ou seja por exemplo uma voz soprano
nós conseguimos a ultrapassar as três
oitavas do título era o seja se quiserem
olhar para um teclado que é dodó central
mas confiamos e província e prosseguindo
ainda mais umas notinhas últimas
notícias abaixo texto a central mas
poder não o levar a conversa por outro
lado é vocês perguntas mas como é que
surge é inato começa logo a tentar áreas
dobra em santos por 11 palco tempo
não de forma alguma a profissão um
cantor lírico em um pouco como a
profissão de um ginasta de alta
competição
por outro lado tem tudo uma componente é
isto do ponto de vista físico por outro
lado tem tudo uma componente intelectual
é nossa profissão está aliada
há muitas outras formas artísticas e
sobretudo a literatura e as línguas é
nos exigido um domínio de pelo menos
cinco idiomas pelo menos até os que
foram mais musicados ao longo da
história da música e sobretudo da
história da obra que vai desde o período
renascentista também nos é exigido que
sejam os cantores atores porque o teatro
que vai desde a grécia antiga e que
muito se discute hoje em dia se as
formas de teatro e de obra estarão pra
acabar
eu não creio que subsiste irão desde os
tempos da grécia antiga e obra desde o
início do fornecimento
acho que estão aqui para ficar as que
estão aqui pra durar porque tem uma
experiência ou pratica uma experiência
teatral normalmente regressa e circuito
porque fica viciado bom como é que como
é que se alimenta esta paixão que surge
e que surgiu quando vi essa tal rocha e
paradoxalmente uma voz sublinha um som
absolutamente transcendente porque nós
vivemos centro no limbo do tocar o
trânsito amt
isso também faz de nós um ser o caminho
especiais porque normalmente quando
tocamos muito transcendente isso
acontece também em outras áreas é muito
difícil realizar uns a terra e serão
capazes de lidar com as questões
práticas não só da vida do cotidiano
como também da vida profissional
[Música]
por outro lado é é um é um paradoxo
porque nos leva porque nós isso por um
lado estamos a tratar em ter os sons de
algo do grande expertise de grande de
grande aperfeiçoamento proto lado temos
que cuidar contudo todo 1
uma guirlanda de construção de
espetáculos com muitas das vezes é muito
muito estressante muito preenchido com
muitas muitas horas de trabalho bom
são muitos anos de aprendizagem são
muitos anos de dia perfeiçoamento e eu
posso dizer qual em toda minha educação
musical e da educação an cultura em
geral há 20 anos ou mais faz um treino
um treino físico é diário
isso consegue ser muito excitante por um
lado mas por outro lado os treinamentos
extremamente difícil de manter a
portugal para estudar numa escola onde
em londres onde eu achei que encontraria
tudo aquilo que não poderia possibilitar
o desenvolvimento do desenvolvimento
todas as capacidades que que tem que se
unir para para que eu conseguisse
atingir os meus objetivos do arrastado
mais uma vez consegui me aproximar
daquela performance que eu tinha
idealizado que tinha ouvido anos é um
treino intensivo muitas línguas muitas
clássico do repertório de 30 muita muita
pressão e isolamento do ponto de vista
musical e quando fizemos um palco da
obra estão muitas formas de arte
reunidas e nós somos apenas mais um em
um instrumento dentro de toda uma
panóplia de d
entre os clientes estão a construir todo
um espetáculo um espetáculo de ópera com
sabem o rio né as mais variadas artes
plásticas tem uma orquestra ao serviço
da música a antes houve um compositor
que escreveu a música os cantores são
intérpretes são cantores e há todo um
livreto foi adaptado normalmente de uma
de uma obra literária tanto aqui tudo o
conjunto considero obra ã o forma de
arte suprema porque não possui profissão
mas porque realmente consegue reunir
todas todas estas estas formas
artísticas no único produto final é uma
profissão muito aliciante do ponto vista
a dar dar voz a uma série de sentimentos
das pressões de emoções através da nossa
interpretação através da nossa voz não é
a voz que é acaba por ser o nosso
instrumento o meu violino passou a ser a
minha voz que existia dentro de mim e eu
consegui cujas capacidades físicas e
mentais adaptar e fazer com que pudesse
ser produzida que está escrito nas
partituras mas por outro lado é minha
voz é como se fosse também um ser
autônomo de mim própria e porque e
vai-vai entra mais uma vez essa questão
quase sobrenatural do sul problema
porque nós temos capacidades que
desconhecemos e muitas vezes temos
instrumentos dentro de nós e nós também
desconhecemos e a nossa capacidade moeda
ambiental é capaz de nos fazer descobrir
propriedades nossas que nos levam a
determinados fingir determinados
objetivos e cumprir determinadas
determinados ideais e eu acho que foi
isso que minha voz
ou não vou descobrir é quando eu
descobri que tinha uma voz não percebi
muito bem que isso era e eu realmente
sentia ter um outro ser que existia
dentro nunca vivi lá dentro me fazia
coisas que eu não não tem se imaginava
não serem um nó que não era possível é e
à medida que fui mudando doença será
autônomo dentro do mundo também percebi
que ela tentava mudar a minha própria e
portanto eu inicio e portanto eu tenho
consciência hoje que minha voz mudou a
minha personalidade é minha voz fez 11 é
caro é que eu sou hoje eu não sei que
carla seria hoje estivesse outra
profissão
se tivesse não tivesse descoberto em
estudo será autônoma dentro de mim que é
minha voz mas realmente é assim eu
quando pisou no palco tem sempre estou
sendo extremamente alerta para todas as
questões técnicas desde musicais desde
cênicas de lingüísticas e literárias
técnicas coreográficas mas também tem
consciência de que há uma espécie de
fenômeno físico que me acompanha durante
todo esse processo é por isso que eu
digo que é bastante mais fácil tentar
pra mim do que falar porque estou aqui
falar com o físico não está a acompanhar
e isto me sinto completamente como se
tivesse despida em frente esta portaria
a a todas estas festas
estas características que nós
desenvolvemos estudamos e aprofundamos
todas elas contribuem para uma energia
especial que se puder de nós quando
pisamos um palco e que nos ajuda é uma
palavra que nos ajuda a
é fazer passar a mensagem da música e do
texto que estamos é cantado
ou seja estamos a citar com nossa voz
cantada quero falar também eu andei o
quando falo de que é uma vida muito
paradoxal é porque tem tanto do belo
como difícil e este sonho eu queria
realmente sentida estar nesta neste maio
de música da literatura que é
absolutamente brilhante e em ambientes
artísticos muito muito muito citado
antes
por outro lado é um ambiente de em
termos do mercado do trabalho
extremamente competitivo e extremamente
difícil difícil pública nós e uns uma
espécie denominada eu tenho sempre malas
abertas em casa estou constantemente a
viajar
o meu trabalho é em vários teatros por
esse mundo fora e portanto não tem
estabilidade é esse nível e o trabalho
constantemente com equipas diferentes
constantemente com com e contratos
diferentes o que também o que também tem
um lado positivo que é o fato de estar
sempre a conhecer gente isso é muito
estimulante e há sempre uma uma estamos
constantemente a sorver novas
informações e conteúdos conhecimentos e
isso é muito bom ficar a toda uma
aprendizagem a todo um desenvolvimento
aliás os artistas não se podem
considerar nunca prefeito só que já
atingiram é o o o nível esperado o
melhor dos artistas aquilo que acha que
ainda tem muito para aprender e tenha
sentido é extremamente desafiante e
extremamente difícil os cantores líricos
são pessoas muito concentradas muito
casas porque fazem da sua vida o
sacerdócio mas por outro lado também são
extremamente frágeis porque me dão com
tantos a tantos aspectos sensíveis
natureza artística e tem uma vida tão
difícil economizar que por si só
extremamente difícil continuar neste
caminho sentidas entenda que os momentos
de quebra e desempenha chega por aqui eu
vou parar por aqui e vou mudar de vida
por vezes até nos fazer isso
transportando a minha experiência para a
realidade portuguesa é com sua profissão
não existe isso porque porque nós temos
muito poucas temporadas ou práticas
temos um único teatro de ópera no país
o teatro e as por razões históricas
manter o centro ou tentou manter sempre
um ambiente de temporadas internacionais
e portanto não não não é um teatro que
ao ver temporadas só com o cantor lírico
na cidade isso neste momento é um
problema porque nós já 20 anos pra cá
quando eu sei portugal não havia
formação capaz de formar um um cantor
lírico em toda sua plenitude
neste momento nós temos muitas
universidades como cursos superiores de
música curso superior de canto
furman movimentos todos os anos saem
dessas necessidades - música quero todos
também no entanto não há mercado de
trabalho e estes cantores muitos deuses
que os que têm e por segurança eu gosto
para continuar saem do país à procura do
mercado internacional certa forma aqui
um contra-senso investiu-se news na na
formação e há 20 anos pra cá mas não se
investiu no mercado de trabalho
a ponte não é ter em portugal uma
cultura do botão
nós temos infra-estruturas absolutamente
incríveis mas não temos
programação que albergue
a edia trabalho aos artistas e aos
músicos em particular destas
instituições onde está a ser investido é
fã do erário público para para que estes
estas pessoas saem informadas tenham
mercado trabalhou só pôde mais dois
minutos para terminar porque me alongar
o que aconteça neste momento nós não
temos isso aconteça um pouco é um pouco
nas artes nós não temos instituições nem
temos uma política de apoio à
continuidade artística por terra
no meu caso um grupo de cantores líricos
portugueses que se mantém no ativo no
país e internacionalmente já é bastante
grande é de muito cuidado e no entanto
nós não temos estruturas em portugal nos
acolheu walken nos requerimentos e é uma
pena isso acontecer porque o que veio do
estrangeiro nem sempre é bom e aquilo
que existem em portugal neste momento da
história é de influência garantiu
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
pergunta sobre a obra frida obra
preferida e até mesmo várias obras
preferidas na seu gosto muito da
história de richard strauss
ariano naxus muito rápidos haydn mozart
em agosto dá um velho e também quem vai
representá lo
[Aplausos]